TODAY.
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE TURN
OUR ATTENTION TO COMMISSIONER
ADAM SILVER.
HE WANTS TO TAKE US THROUGH A
COUPLE OF THINGS.
ADAM, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> YOU, TOO, COACH.
SORRY TO INTERRUPT YOUR MEETING.
AS YOU SAID, I HAVE SOME
IMPORTANT NEWS.
THAT IS THAT IT'S MY HONOR TO
ANNOUNCE THAT NIKOLA JOKIC IS
THIS YEAR'S MOST VALUABLE
PLAYER.
CONGRATULATIONS, NIKOLA.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST MVP IN
NUGGETS HISTORY.
ALL RIGHT?
AND THE FIRST MVP IN THE SECOND
ROUND.
SECOND ROUND MVP, FIRST-EVER AND
FIRST IN FRANCHISE HISTORY.
AND FIRST OF MANY.
>> THANK YOU.
I JUST WANT TO TELL THE GUYS
THIS IS NOT MINE.
IT IS AN HONOR BUT I COULDN'T DO
IT WITHOUT YOU GUYS.
IT'S MY TROPHY, WHATEVER, BUT
YOU GUYS WILL BE A PART